we're on the after-show van how do you
maintain friendships with ardent Trump
supporters like Jeffrey Lord and Kaley
mcenany I hard drugs no no I don't do
drugs all you guys that love it I
actually never use never had a drink
either I thought I felt so bad oh good
feel bad anyway so uh I don't know what
you're missing it I never too late I
well I could get you [ __ ] up frankly
hang around Jeffrey Lord has got me
pretty [ __ ] up stuff yeah oh thank you
man Johnson you leave here
I just bow jog I just see man we do CNN
together Caitlin he's always just a nice
guy to people offset and I appreciate
that I appreciate that I tell you why
everybody's focus by uh ever listen no
no this is pure self-interest
everybody's focused on Tuesday the day
of the election I'm focused on Wednesday
the day after the election right when
the Trump voters are not leaving America
the Clinton voters are not leaving
America black lives matter is not
leaving and the cops aren't leaving
you're all gonna be here together you
need to start working it out that's
right
Chelsea how would you compare sexism in
Hollywood to sexism and politics um I
guess you know sexism is pretty I mean
rampant everywhere I think watching
Hillary and have her having her do this
like to think about what somebody goes
through for any campaign and then to
think that she's done this so many times
like and the idea that that's that's
labeled like to all the young girls that
are growing up in this country that's
she's vilified so much because she's got
ambition mm-hmm like yeah you think why
are we saying that that's bad that
agenda her agenda is public service
she's got evil yeah she's not perfect
you know they do something like sketchy
things that's I'm okay with it like I'm
okay with a little bit of that I don't
think she's she I think that the sexism
plays such a major role in this thing is
it you have the most qualified woman a
person no no I want I want keep it
gender the most qualified woman in the
history of the world versus the least
qualified human being to do anything at
all on your show when he said earlier
about if this were a black man it's like
if the Hillary were you know if Hillary
had filed bankruptcy four times with
huge fuel for huge casinos if she had
been caught on tape saying these things
if she done half of this [ __ ] she
wouldn't be a nominee he's a whole the
whole deal about very honestly about
Hillary being the most qualified person
I'm like what has she done I know she
Syria hundred thousand people that have
been murdered in Syria that's divorce
you don't really I'm saying we've the
[ __ ] away I are not been a single
advance from the Secretary of State
we've done the networking was just she
was at an Auto Show
Halla site official bit and look what
the Secretary of State she cannot
control the world what so it's not
really only weird way to travel to 100
countries before you four years doing
working out in ago so how many alliances
did she build
0-neg invested on truth that's a true
other country yes this Christian Asia I
didn't give you today no we have NATO it
was built in 1942 exactly how the other
[ __ ] wants to get rid of it well I'm
not I'm just saying I just call out I
told everything but once you change to
her we show you something that's not the
same every one did once once ordered
didn't make me just honestly um I'll
give you qu one uh Hamas Israel they
could have been in the massive I'm you
have had dead children across the Middle
East
she got in there and stopped it in 12
hours that is very very different by the
way also Libya was about stopping dead
children and that was a humanity that we
got in there for a humanitarian reason
and the other you forget that and the
other thing is let's not forget but she
gets credit for that think about but not
does not take it could make any blame
for Syrian reasons well are y'all
continuing blame for Syria why you
shouldn't blame but you're the person
did she's a top foreign policy you know
but official and the administration but
you're saying she could get on the phone
to the nefarious people we can't even
identify who are fighting the government
and tell these people who we don't even
who they are don't do it no I'm saying
that she it's just in she said they
could have had a safe passage for
Refugees they could have grounded the of
course so she was a fan of the Russian
reset don't forget your goodbye your
calendars you so screwed up she wasn't
even positioned by that point but I'll
give you one what Trump always says that
Chubby's his in the debates he's like as
if she's been there for 30 years yes as
first lady she should have personally
rewritten the tax code so didn't write
oh I'm not gonna let you get away with
this I'm not listening seriously all
right Iran she she has no alliances she
went and got Russia she went and got
China and most of the world to squeeze
Iran in a way they got it they got us
out of a fast-track under george w bush
for them to have nuclear weapons that is
very tough to do what have you done by
the way
No
first of all I'll say number one I was
the author of the public hazard reform
the biggest housing reform in 60 years
actually two number one number two I was
the author of a bill that allowed
disabled people to go back to work and
keep their health care and wideouts job
guys sign into law half of Rick so I'm
rapping but I'm just saying what do you
think you go about the cattle futures
Rick okay put on the cattle team I was
just sleeping to switch with that a new
round off that wondered all right okay
thank you everybody
[Applause]